welcome to this 15-minute game see you
won't see you Inga hmm probably totally
butchering this up from from Spain let's
see do the bank of it and plate this
home on a case declining with Knight f3
after nada 3 I can't actually transpose
to the Blumenfeld this was a fun
recently right so let's do this
after not a three there are many other
interesting moves before g6 Bishop d7
okay well but the bloom of thought is
interesting and a half at least awake
idea about it so why not
okay they accept it
I think they usually do that
play this first and then be fired I'm
not totally sure but I in in a recent
game I had played d5 immediately and
then white played III and somehow kept
the b5 pond
yeah what does not really seem to have
anything prepared here yeah this is a
common occurrence in the the Blumenthal
to play it and quickly notice that the
white player is not really am
well-versed in things it's not not too
surprising because it's just an opening
that is not played very often and yeah
you of course focus on the lines that
that you get on the board often and how
often do you get this type of gambit
probably close to never and this makes
it even more interesting for black to to
investigate and I mean it's very often
quite quite simple to play I mean you
you have the center and the very healthy
aggressive development so it's not it's
not so so tough to to even find over the
board okay so what white is doing he
wants to play a form in response to e5
so if I go if I he will play a form try
to open up the the light squares in the
center I don't want to play Bishop a6
twiddly as this would somehow give him a
tempo I want to make this kind of
strengthening move introducing the idea
to go to h5 at the right moment and I
might take on a6 but I don't want to
take in a position where he can take
from everyone on 86 so trying to win a
tempo like here here Bishop is six is a
more interesting choice however still
what about if 5 p.m.
five D takes d5 sorry II five F or yeah
D takes D [ __ ]
he even has he even does he have even as
Knight takes e4 e5 e 4 de 4 94 94 25
check hmm that's not very nice so if one
is a constant variant in response to my
5 IDM how to how to continue then hmm if
I perform I don't want to play d4 and
I'm not sure about Bishop 860m if he
takes on a 6 ok 6 the rook is it is
slightly misplaced on a6 I would like to
play 595 34 maybe I should prepare this
King h8 is useful in most cases anywhere
anyway with the F pawn having moved
already
okay what about Queen age 5 and that's
95 not not so great if I go a 5 e form
now we can play for very nice
so should I just take it on a six
getting one pawn back it's not what I
wanted
I wonder about a 5 e 4g for I know it
gives up
c4 especially but still it is it is
relatively and it sector the ship on P 2
is also Hampton but still and it's not
really convincing ok I'll take that this
is also taking at night sieve form
technically on the d6 Bishop yeah I
wonder is it is it may be here an idea
to not play on the kingside wow he just
played g3 without being provoked that's
surprising
I don't really I don't really understand
it why would you play g3 I mean totally
unforced hmm
okay still he five has probably study
for as a response okay now I go to a sir
this is a move that I had thought of
anyway because a possible Queen e2
always it takes the rook the rook is
unprotected here it can swing over to f7
at the right moment and there I cannot
be attacked easily and after g3 and
pretty much guaranteed to have some sort
of attack with queen h5 queen adria rook
f7 and who is playing that justice just
like that
yes threatening a fire that's that's
certainly true okay if I take on if for
there is what Knight g5
oh no Bishop f6 simply and taking on e4
hmm okay so Knight g4 maybe directly
yeah I guess so
I mean if I this as a serious threat or
was a serious threat yeah here I have
the idea to go to e5 c5 to d3 in an
ideal scenario even to to d3
hmm yeah III still shocked me a bit
before ever was an interesting move yeah
here there are many many technical
possibilities that I simply couldn't
calculate for example 85 85 94 takes on
c4 Queen d6 probably rook f3 as possible
but it is a very weak back rank and not
very weak but it's a weak background
galaxy for us probably not a great idea
yeah yeah here see a Queenie to the rook
on a6 would have been attacked with the
tempo and now there is nothing like that
okay Queen H life is looking like in
normal moves Knight h4 could be a good
response intending to play Age 3
yeah but still come on let's let's play
the most active move or let's say active
looking with an IDE edge 4 I should have
some sort of response I don't I haven't
decided yet on anything concrete but
there should be something maybe Bishop
e5 my play displayed quickly maybe
Bishop e5 this in a way would to win the
temple Bishop takes Knight exd5
still age 3 mmm
yeah I played it if I just thought okay
there will be something but at the
moment I don't I don't see a move roogie
have said 'no maybe we would have 7h3
rook takes F to this this could work
because at the end there's always
something hanging on d2 but
look eight seven eight three rope checks
f2h takes G for rook takes it - it's
just a piece down right yep hmm yeah
then this is probably strong night age
for I was really hoping that there is
nothing dangerous coming but I didn't
didn't calculate as mentioned
yeah maybe Queen g5 I mean it's not it's
not ideal at all but I really think h3
is a threat actually huh what can I do
therefore I can take on f4 at least I
hope and I hope it at least Knight f3 I
can go back to h5 because h3 I can
return to f6 or to e5 both possible
yeah this kind of opening a surreal
really great for for people who have
very good calculation skills yes please
play and complicated clashes in the
center happen all along and there's so
many loose pieces which is really an bit
uncommon for my type of game Bishop d6
uncovered knight c6 uncovered everything
sort of loose and makes it somewhat
tricky to play for me easily blunder
stuff my donk
yeah here I thought just go back to h5
of course if he retreats gd2
just saying alright you 400 450 points
higher rated how are you going to win
now then this is an issue but white has
some comfortable position anyway I guess
yeah I'm not sure comfortable that's
maybe a bit strong but a strong word
yeah he's really asking this question
how am I going to make any progress it's
very tough very tough to to try to
continue okay I can repeat once and here
maybe after 93 maybe here I have some
some other moves
what about Queen age six
yeah maybe come on not here to play
drawers all day
No maybe that's not so bad it's really
very much dependent on concrete timing
if I let's just say it would would be my
move in this position then I'm playing
rook a to f7 and I'm fine
okay should I recapture I wonder if I
take if there's Knight f5 maybe
something like that rook takes Queen EA
check it's not winning or anything I'm
not really okay
so he's a checking in a way d5 and the
Queen trade if I go to age five probably
Queen g5 coming just trying to get the
Queen's off okay but let's let's do this
and play Knight to before I mean okay
it's a queen trade but still I have some
initiative a to is hanging and there is
93 with the threat against the bishop
and against f2 now that's not that's not
that's not clear-cut at all I have seen
a very active pieces
hmm yeah
one possible move is actually to take on
f2 with 93 to be 2 at the end
rook takes rook takes and take on g7 but
that's not not really helping much
because of Bishop b5 and rook a to at
the end so probably you should and I
think this is a mistake
unless and unless I'm blundering stuff
as possible of course I think this is a
mistake do to Bishop e5 and rook a to
Bishop e5 yeah I think it's fine he can
he does not have a good place for the
rook rook e1 that's 93 and wherever it
goes was after rook a to is in a very
awkward pin yeah blacks initiative is
lasting right to this this endgame yeah
but the relatively best square I guess
let's take him no I'm threatening Bishop
c3
okay
Bishop deform maybe that's another five
okay okay okay
Bishop okay probably here I am and then
to the forum
night everyone Bishop III Ellis looks
looks quite promising still that's not a
five i'ma keep overlooking night at five
check isn't this amazing
okay so if he goes through to f1 I'm not
playing Bishop before please not to the
ship before me what do i do instead I
can maybe I can I'm not sure
can I just attack to be born Ruby to
what should I play should i play
something to to limit his options like
King f6 yeah I'm just controlling their
five square not easy I can also think
about night c2 to deform but I think he
can he can take on d5 maybe I should
just play d4
yes just taking away e3 if that's very
good that very good square and that
still can play look a3 or rugby to
taking the pawn Jack yeah probably this
was this was right
okay now Knight g3 as it's possibly
coming so I go here and take the pawn
yeah
let's assess this is a chick
this is a chicken farm hmm it's no
really good way what can I go no I
cannot cannot go to the five
I'm playing this rather rather slowly
can i deform not quite sure if there's
something else
I don't see how I can protect this I
would really love to but King B 593 is
not helping
yeah that's not great I mean really I
really thought I was was was better and
this is this is not not great at all
I mean not great at all it's a bit a bit
harsh but it's not like black is winning
or anything I have more activity but
that's just one porn left yeah that's it
two points but two points but the dis
pawn on d4 has a possible winner in a
way okay I can play an age five maybe
get in this this this rook okay everyone
or dislodge the night okay this this is
this is what you can do of course time
warning check for Luke
offered for rook and Bishop yeah I don't
know I can take it but I have a run
relatively little risk here he's not
he's not playing so quickly
need to win the pond first check
yeah maybe I should have taken it I
don't know I don't like to take draws
Jeff
check
now the rook air-five is not a winner
Jack looks a bit bit silly for a wild
but it's not it's not winning what what
he went to g4 yeah I thought he went he
would go to g3 yeah this is the way from
white to win the game okay okay black
resigned yeah I was just thinking about
about this I wanted to give the cheque
of course basically a Primavera yeah I
will win the H Paul and then look Luca
and Bishop against Lucas is a draw but
most people cannot defend it so this is
why I wanted to continue even with 40
seconds assembly it's a basically a pre
move here I thought that he would go to
g3 didn't expect to
kingi form and jam
did a pretty good job of defending this
this pretty awful position I mean I
certainly made mistakes but this
probably being doing the real one tough
tough tough tough tough
now I need to address this idea maybe
this is more precise if he now activates
this this night see to attending night
you one that's very very dangerous
yeh around here black is really winning
the computer is on - - and this is
probably very very decisive but I didn't
I didn't really find it night is 6 here
hmm
didn't like the move at all yeah this is
the draw but my last night a 6 good I
didn't because here I cannot go gay one
we can't do this yeah why is this
possible I don't get a true k6r then I
have this this check here chat window in
the night okay okay okay oh okay I know
I didn't I didn't consider this then
night is six is strong it simply keeps
the pawn check maybe here instead of age
five
rook you want look upon this mess better
I don't know there are still some
chances to win the Jamie the game chat
like this check here's something else
maybe I don't know you get four or
something it's tough to avoid the rook
and rook and Bishop against Luke endgame
that's really tough him maybe there are
possibilities to do it but it's probably
at wrong
yeah at the enter and she made this this
Prince blunder which is always a bit
frustrating because you basically throw
away a 30-minute game or 30 minute long
game with such an idiotic move but ok I
just only reckoned with both the King a
g3 which is the far more normal move and
in a way but ok I didn't didn't just
just here played basically preemies
alright thanks for watching